hey guys tim ferriss here i'm going to
show you how I went from very grumpy
baby to slightly happier baby and for
those of you don't know what happy baby
is it looks like this refer to a lot in
yoga it's something like this and
another way to think of it would be like
this this type of position and I've
always had a lot of difficulty with it
it's extremely important for a lot of
things the highly specific AcroYoga
things like that which I'll show in a
minute and then you have just general
hip health and there are many ways to
improve that position I stalled for
probably a year and a half two years
huge huge pain and turned out a few
things were very helpful for me weighted
stretches combined with presses and a
few other things I'm going to show you
the sequence that I have found most
helpful it's going to be within the
context of AcroYoga
so kiplyn this is my friend capelin sag
miller ask kiplyn ki p li NN on all the
socials let's do some bird presses first
so this is a position macro yoga called
bird and i'm going to be placing my feet
basically on her hip bones right here so
no my feet are gonna be right here and
you'll see as I go through this what
we're going to do the safest way to get
into it so we can do it with no hands if
we do it no hands it looks like that
okay generally if we come down we're
going to use hands be flier I'm the base
flier fingers forward it's a good way to
remember it and we're just going to come
up like that so very often I would do
the presses with the hands so that would
look like this okay but I these days use
it with no hands and when I do this
pointing with the toes slightly I'm
bringing the knees down and I am trying
to keep my tailbone on the ground the
temptation will be to roll up and I want
to try to keep this seated and then I
will pull down with my hands to
to the ground and if your feet starts
flipping out you can just correct with
the hands you can squeeze the hand to
indicate where you want to place the
weight readjust the foot pretty just the
foot and then we continue and I'll
typically do 6 repetitions of this only
going to do 2 right now so it come down
you can kind of play with the balance of
feet pointing and so on then coming back
up to 90 degrees
I'll do one more and you can see you can
kind of play with positioning really
trying to pull down into grumpy baby /
happy
so that's part one alright now what I
have found is that just putting yourself
into this position for extended periods
of time doesn't work for me so I will do
6 repetitions you notice 5 or 6
repetitions into max depth just for a
second or two and then out and what I
found is that there's a compression on
the leg when my legs are straight and
I'll show you another example of that in
just a few minutes then there's traction
so Kipling you want to show just the
feet behind the hips traction so you can
do this in as partners where you turn
the feet in and she's just leaning back
on my feet which is giving me a nice
amount of traction hips so I will do
this in between many of these exercises
Thank You Kip fun and I'll also do that
for my wrists so this is not limited to
the hips I will get say a towel of some
type and I will pull on the fingers I'm
getting a lot of handstand work or
something like that so this is all
transferable
okay so we have bird press number one
number two I'm working on internal and
external rotation of the leg and both
legs independently so we're going to do
a cartwheel into side start and I'll
also show you some stuff that is not
accurate dependent but so if we come up
and then we'll go on to the opposite
side here alright so I'm getting this
compression on a single leg
and you'll notice that kiplyn has
effectively 90-degree angle between her
legs here this this foot the bottom foot
is actually very close to the ground
okay and will do generally five to six
reps on either side is what I typically
do as part of the warmup
alright so we're going to cartwheel out
now what we're going to do is instead of
having a good amount of external
rotation we focus on internal rotation
and we will do that going from the bird
position which you've already seen to a
slightly different type of upside star
so from here I'm going to [ __ ] one foot
out and then kiplyn is going to slide
onto that foot you'll see how she uses
their arm support now this then we get
this rotation and this internal rotation
on this leg now when I come back watch
how I bend my legs I'm going to push
with this support leg and catch the
other foot that we come up then internal
rotation and this one is very tough for
a lot of women and a lot of guys in
particular guys with stiff hips that
don't rotate worth a damn it's a very
therapeutic exercise also teaches you
how to have soft feet if you're doing
more AcroYoga or anything that includes
some form of hamstring flexibility okay
let's dismount so we come down alright
so I want to show a few things that are
not accurate dependent then I sometimes
do in between these exercises so one of
them I'll come over is this so this is a
rad roller and one of the guests of my
podcast
Amelia Boone has the world's most
successful female obstacle course racer
taught me and ended coach summer so
Chris summer former national team coach
for men's gymnastics
in the u.s. that people think of
hamstring flexibility oftentimes the
restrictions they're like Oh can't touch
my toes are related to the lower legs
and the feet so I will roll out my feet
like so and I will travel with this rad
roller this is not very exciting to
watch but you'll get the idea so foot is
right in the middle here and I'll
generally do it very slowly and then
I'll [ __ ] it out like so and then in and
you can you can accelerate a lot of your
hamstring flexibility progress so I'll
do this on the feet also very good for
the forearms you can roll them on the
floor when you're doing a lot of
handstand or straighter part okay
good idea I don't always do this but
it's tuned gourds of the calves and
stretch the Achilles and the calves
before you do your hamstring work it was
making a lot easier alright now I'll
show you a few things because I will
often take a break before the next one
because I find it have found it
historically very difficult getting a
lot easier other things that I will do
is I'll focus on back rotation also to
get the mid-back and traps and lats
engage but this is a kind of a modified
like mark for Stegen type of movement
think Eric Cressey also uses something
very similar I will get into this type
of lunge position what's very important
is that my hips are square I'm not doing
this I'm not doing this it's not a
warrior post type of thing toes are
pointing straight ahead and then what
I'll do is simply drop this elbow flat
to the ground and then come up pinch
this leg in and rotate it okay and then
if that is easy I'll just change the
foot forward and do it again and as per
usual I will do probably six of these
alright and then you just do it on the
opposite side
and we're just going to kind of match
range for a second and then right out
we're not staying for 30 seconds for non
staying for two minutes that there are
options for that but I don't do them as
part of this warmup okay and once we've
done all that there's one last that I'd
recommend especially for guys this is
just a general warmup
recommendation instead of just
stretching this way stretching this way
focusing on what we just did
just rotation and an easy way to do that
is like this and this is I'm going to
blank on with last name I apologize
you've also heaps siddell but I don't
think that's right see it was basically
the team doc also a competitor at
Paradiso CrossFit in Venice showed me
this tweak which is not just in free
standing or free squatting rotation but
using a wall to ensure that you don't
cheat that your hips don't translate so
in this case have my hips my shoulder
peg to the wall and I'm just going to be
crowing down I'm coming straight up and
I asked him well if you have pain in
your back how do you know if you should
do the exercise or not and his answer
was if it feels better as you go after
say five repetitions and your range of
motion is increased that means you do
the movement so that is that and then
the final move that I'll show you is
called a well one is a star press and
then you have a walk to star and I'll
show you what that is so I like to start
with the negative what does that mean
negative we have concentric and then
eccentric movement so the concentric
movement you can see the bicep is
contracting it's getting shorter then as
you lower it's getting longer
that's the eccentric or negative so I
start with negatives with star and then
go to walk ups and we'll show you
exactly who that is so probably good to
face this way to show this all right so
the hand grip for those of you might be
wondering is like this this is
grip that we're using sort of two
fingers on the wrist and then the hands
wrapped as so and we're trying to
maintain a comfortable angle this is
flat this is steep you usually end up
somewhere in-between and you just like
dancing with a partner we've figured out
so what grip works for us okay all right
so this is star and very often the hands
for the arms of the flyer in this case
kiplyn I'm going to be straight they can
be bent we can do some crazy stuff like
free star which we don't have to do
right now which is no hands
but the presses so the negative I
mentioned I'm just going to lower like
so and then all right back up I'm going
to the same on the opposite side just
like that notice this is very grumpy
baby and then they come up and then from
here I would do that probably two or
three reps on either side and we're just
going to walk down to that this is bad
or straddle bad then we're going to walk
up all right so this would be pretty
self-explanatory just like so and you
just do that on both sides and two pops
for fun
and then I'll show you guys what a pop
is just for fun don't try this at home
you need professional supervision ready
well - and then you can go back
tada and that ladies and gents
especially if you utilizing a credo
which i think is a great way to improve
hip health Forel basing what I was doing
that is how you can go over time but
pretty quickly in my case from very
grumpy baby to happy baby if you enjoyed
this video I have more to share all of
the tools tactics cool things that I'm
finding five bullet Friday it is an
exclusive newsletter it's completely
free I sent it out every Friday just has
five bullet points with the coolest most
useful things that I found or revisiting
that week and you can find it by
clicking here takes about five minutes
to read super short very actionable
bible to friday also found at 4-hour
workweek comm board slash friday